great Marsha Blackburn she's going to
try to get the Epstein Client List since
we're in the business of issuing
subpoenas now here are a few more that I
filed a subpoena to Jeffrey Epstein's
estate to provide the flight logs for
his private plane given the numerous
allegations of human trafficking and
sexual abuse surrounding Mr Epstein I
think it is very important that we
identify everybody that was on that
plane and how many trips they took on
that plane and the destinations to which
they arrived of course that's great love
that Marsh is doing this one of the
great senators in Washington DC why has
this taken so long